are you sitting comfortably we know a
good chair is hard to find maybe you're
watching this on your phone while you
lie in bed or maybe you're watching at
your desk sitting in an office chair
maybe you're even watching it while
you're in the bathroom it's fine we're
not here to judge for our money you just
can't beat a nice classic wooden chair
with soft leather upholstery call us
old-fashioned but some things just never
go out of style take a chair like
scp-1609 for example this fine piece of
mahogany was once a chair that simply
couldn't be beat in its quest to bring
its users a little dose of comfort and
refinement in their daily life tell us
have you ever been on your feet all day
just walking and walking and walking and
at a certain point you're just begging
for a nice comfy chair that'll let you
take the weight off your feet for a
little while you would have been
scp-1609's favorite kind of person after
all it was the only chair that literally
sought out weary travelers and even did
you the courtesy of tucking itself in
that's not a metaphor either
scp-1609 could literally teleport to
nearby people who needed to sit down and
didn't have a chair to fulfill that
desire it was nothing but a nice helpful
anomaly that wanted to help people rest
when they needed it most the more
observant members of you have noticed
that we've been using the past tense so
far that's because while
scp-1609 is still an active anomaly it
isn't a chair anymore and this
transformation wasn't something that
scp-1609 planned anticipated or even
wanted the story of 1609's
transformation even strikes to the core
of one of the foundation's oldest and
most bitterly held rivalries with
another group of interest it's the tale
of how a helpful piece of anomalous
furniture became a paranoid killer but
first we need to talk about containment
procedures like a word you see so often
that it starts to lose meaning
containment and specific containment
procedures are concepts so integral to
the very existence of the scp foundation
that it is easy to overlook or forget
about them they're one of the three core
pillars of the foundation's mission
statement secure contain protect because
of the centrality of containment to the
foundation's core principles one of the
most valuable roles on the scp
foundation payroll is that of the
containment specialist a vast team of
experts who work with researchers to
figure out the best way to keep every
anomaly contained based on their unique
abilities and attributes they're
zookeepers archivists guards security
and intelligence experts magicians
practitioners of ritual scientists and
so much more in short they're anything
they need to be in order to adapt to the
ever-evolving containment needs of the
anomalies they keep under lock and key
and containment isn't easy aside from
the rare safe class scps which require
incredibly minimal containment resources
the containment of most scps extracts
some kind of cost whether that be
financial time effort or in some
particularly dark cases human life some
scps like scp-974
and
scp-2845 require the sacrifice of human
children to prevent worse fates
befalling many others other scps like
the infamous scp-231 require the
foundation to do horrifying things to
the scp itself to prevent it from
manifesting some even more horrifying
anomalous traits and a third but equally
inconvenient kind of scp like scp-682
and scp-076
require huge numbers of heavily armed
guards with powerful weapons to keep
their deadly prisoners locked away often
at a massive risk to their own lives
containment isn't easy but it's
ultimately the very thing that makes the
scp foundation the organization it is if
they were instead on a quest to kill and
destroy every anomaly they could get
their hands on then they'd be the global
occult coalition the un's answer to the
scp foundation that prefers to seek
disable and destroy rather than secure
contain and protect it's the primary
characteristic that differentiates these
two titans of the anomalous world who
regularly come to blows and right at the
heart of that difference is scp-1609
as we mentioned earlier
scp-1609 went through a transformation
that changed everything but the scp
foundation never actually knew about the
anomaly prior to that transformation
taking place it first came to their
attention when it literally manifested
within a containment cell in storage
site-08 making the rare move of
willingly submitting itself to the
foundation containment but what showed
up in that cell certainly wasn't a chair
when 1609 appeared all it looked like
was a pile of trash specifically
splinters wood chippings furniture nails
and scraps of bleached leather and
fabric anything that suddenly
infiltrates a secure foundation
containment site is cause for concern
even a bunch of wood scraps so the site
director sent in an armed guard to
investigate the mysterious pile of
debris
researchers watching over a surveillance
feed were surprised when the guard
suddenly entered a state of heightened
distress he fell to his knees coughing
and spluttering until he expelled a
considerable amount of blood from his
mouth and nose he then collapsed on the
ground next to the pile of debris
dead an investigation following this
incident found that the guard had died
after a sudden influx of jagged metal
and wood had teleported inside of him
tearing his lungs apart from the inside
and causing the guard to die a painful
and horrific death naturally the site
personnel were somewhat concerned by
this development they sent in a d-class
to investigate further but were
surprised to find that the d-class in
question was somehow completely fine the
pile of debris that would soon be
designated
scp-1609 made no attempt to harm the
d-class as it had the guard and finding
out why this was the case came as a side
effect of figuring out exactly what had
happened to
scp-1609 through a rigorous
investigation involving more than one
secret foundation mole they discovered
that scp-1609 had previously been in the
possession of you guessed it the global
occult coalition back then it was just a
helpful chair you once knew and loved
until the goc had the bright idea of
forcing it into a wood chipper in order
to destroy it due to its connection to
someone called the carpenter but all the
goc's attempt actually succeeded in
doing was altering its form and
completely changing its personality to
put it in simple terms
scp-1609 is now a pile of possibly
sentient teleporting wood and metal
chippings that suffers from a nasty case
of ptsd the incident with the wood
chipper traumatized scp-1609
and its anxiety is triggered by anything
that reminds it of the goc or the wood
chipper incident this includes wearing
formal clothing lab coats protective
clothing jumpsuits and particularly body
armor but also includes anyone carrying
weapons appearing outwardly aggressive
using common goc lingo or even
mentioning the goc in
scp-1609's proximity if any of this
happens it's extremely likely that
scp-1609 will resort to its only natural
defense mechanism which is teleporting
its debris into the lungs of anyone it
considers to be a threat the guard had
received this grisly punishment because
his clothes weapon and overall manner
caused
scp-1609 to regard him as a threat and
react accordingly you may think this is
overkill on 1609's part but if you were
just trying to help out the chairless
people of the world then someone fed you
into a wood chipper you'd probably be a
little jumpy too since these early days
the foundation has learned to apply a
more tender touch when it comes to
dealing with scp-1609
and the brilliant containment
specialists even figured out a way to
keep 1609 happily contained by placing
it in a flower bed inside its
containment chamber where its wood chips
get to serve as mulch for a variety of
flowers and plants all attending
researchers and guards dress in plain
clothes and adopt a loose pleasant
attitude while inside whenever they're
around they make a point of saying how
beautiful the flower bed is so that the
disfigured anomaly that only ever wanted
to be helpful can still feel like it's
doing something nice because of these
containment procedures breaches
involving
scp-1609 have remained in the single
digits it is a perfect example of less
really being more when it comes to
containment the head researcher on the
scp-1609 case dr sivert released an
internal document permanently affixed to
the file like a kind of cautionary
signpost it's a clear expression of
exasperation and rage at the actions of
the global occult coalition reading
scp-1609 represents a perfect example of
the flaws inherent in the operating
procedure of the goc and serves as a
cautionary tale for any members of the
foundation who disagree with our
practices on containing dangerous
objects prior to the coalition getting
their hands on this it was perfectly
harmless a chair which teleports to you
when you need to see it as normal
compared to most of the stuff that we
deal with on a regular basis when they
put it through a wood chipper they got
hurt scared and angry so it lashed out
at them by trying to protect the world
by destroying it they inadvertently made
the situation a whole lot worse
scp-1609 went from being harmless to
deadly in the space of a few minutes
because of the goc and we had to clean
up the mess thankfully
scp-1609 is pretty simple for us to deal
with so long as we don't have to do
anything stupid around it it won't fight
back and it won't try to leave even if
it does it usually comes back and i
think i've worked out why it came to us
because it was afraid of the people who
had heard it that's why it always comes
back it's afraid of the rest of the
world now and it's looking to us for
protection this is why we have special
containment procedures instead of
special destruction procedures if you
break something it's broken forever when
you try to destroy an anomaly you can't
take back your mistakes that's what
scp-1609 has to tell us this is why
we're right and the goc is wrong people
but of course there are two sides to
every story and it's important to
understand the goc's perspective on this
whole mess to them this has never been
scp-1609
it's
kte-0937 velveteen aka the sixth chair
it was labeled as the sixth because for
the goc this chair was merely one part
of a wider investigation it belonged to
a six-piece furniture set created by a
dangerous anomalous person of interest
named the carpenter for a classified
customer the goc was able to intercept
this deal and kill the carpenter and his
customer in the process after that all
that was left was to eliminate the
anomalous objects and five of them were
incinerated without incident however
before they could do the same to the
sixth chair they experienced an
incinerator malfunction rather than just
waiting for the incinerator to be fixed
a member of goc personnel decided to
rush the job and run the chair through a
wood chipper it was at this point that
its pieces first lashed out invading the
lungs of this negligent goc member along
with five others killing them all it was
shortly after that that
scp-1609 manifested in foundation
containment much like dr severt did for
the foundation assistant director
kipling one of the goc's legion of
middle managers affixed a note to the
profile of kte 0937 velveteen that reads
kte-0937 velveteen is an object lesson
in the importance of following proper
operating procedures due to the lack of
vigilance by the agent on the scene the
object's threat level was escalated the
object itself was not successfully
disposed of and has since fallen into
the hands of a hostile agency a single
failure by a single operative resulted
in the deaths of six remember this next
time you think about cutting corners and
that's a good lesson for everyone
whether you're trying to destroy an
anomalous piece of furniture or keeping
its remains happy so they don't try to
kill you cutting corners is always a
fast track to failure now check out scp
global occult coalition explained and
scp-5000 why the full story compilation
for more dramatic clashes between the
global occult coalition and the scp
foundation